one of the primary ways that i identify
myself is as a maker
once i got to mit as a freshman i found
an extracurricular activity that really
caught my eye
it was called trash in show and it was
all about creating fashion out of
unconventional materials to promote a
theme of sustainability
my first design seen on the left here
was made of trash bags duct tape and
plastic party tablecloths
one of my later designs seen on the
right was made primarily out of old
books and lace curtains and was held
together with paperclips and binder
rings
i decided to take a famous class at mit
called toy product design
it sounded fun and it would give me the
chance to explore mechanical engineering
my inner maker was satisfied and at the
same time i was learning the math and
science behind
product design later i took a class on
manufacturing where we created 50 bb-8
yoyos that moved like the actual
character from star wars
for my capstone design project my team
worked to create a hands-free sheet
music page turner
we interviewed different musicians to
learn about their needs
and even visited a musical instrument
workshop to learn about what kinds of
tools and techniques
should be used to create something that
fits the look and feel of a professional
instrument
i began finding opportunities in the
world of engineering for entertainment
i had the chance to prototype and build
an escape room that was themed around
being stuck in a jar of candy
it started with a storyboard of an
experience and i created a mini model of
the room
with pipe cleaner humans playing around
on real jelly beans
i also went to work for an animatronics
company
this company creates dinosaurs and other
animatronic creatures for theme parks
and broadway shows
i got the opportunity to work with the
sculptural fabrication team
to try and determine a more efficient
way to make dinosaur skins
usually they're completely hand designed
with each skill cut
by hand and arranged instead i tried
using a mold
to get a bunch of scale shapes at once
then i attached them to a styrofoam
block
before covering them with epoxy and
fiberglass so they could eventually be
painted
this significantly decreased the time it
would take to create dinosaur skins and
it was really neat to get to help with
that process
all of these experiences have taught me
the secret about art and stem
in fact they don't need to be combined
they are one and the same
the examples go on people who sow use
patterns and measurements the way
engineers use and create engineering
drawings to know how to build something
perfecting recipes is really running a
series of chemistry experiments and
drawing scientific conclusions
poetry and programming are both all
about precision in choosing words
to have a specific outcome whether
that's evoking an emotion
or giving an instruction to a computer
crochet topology
is actually a category of math
mathematicians have been using crochet
to understand complex geometries of
structures
additionally the way you have to keep
track of stitches and patterns
really requires precision and
mathematical thinking
and beginning to connect the dots that
all my creating and crafting as a child
was the same as the iterating and
prototyping that i do as an engineer and
as a designer
it was never framed that way for me
growing up because i saw a very
different narrative of engineering and
science portrayed
i wasn't interested in cars or airplanes
so i didn't think
mechanical engineering would be
interesting to me at the same time
i was building and creating things not
realizing that what i was really doing
was building up my engineering skills a
lot of times people will say to me oh
it's so interesting that you have
interests in these very different areas
but to me
it's they're one in the same it's two
sides of
who i am and i think being an artist
makes me a better engineer and being an
engineer makes me a better artist